tous les ordres
trois cent cinquante et un ans après
l'arrivée des premiers habitants sur
l'île de la réunion 144 élèves s'envole
dans le cadre de l'opération lancée par
le conseil général sur les traces de nos
racines leurs destinations la bretagne
le mozambique madagascar la chine et
l'inde pour le collège de montgaillard
ce n'est plus qu'une question de jours
avant le départ pour le pays de gandhi
malgré qu'il qui vont découvrir autre
chose une autre culture déjà de la
réunion c'est surtout leur leur prouver
qu'ils sont capables à leur âge d'être
autonomes et qu'ils peuvent commencer à
se débrouiller un peu tout seul et ça
les prépare également à la vie active en
vue du scrutin qui veut pas inquiet je
suis premier à craquer rentrer dans le
bios et justin convaincu lui sylvie n'a
fait aussi partie de ceux qui prendront
l'avion pour la première fois sa
stratégie pour gérer ses angoisses
l'humour j'aimerais bien me en un an ti
ce revenu en nantes est la règle
et
changer un peu de dire je le souhaite
bon voyage à tous ces collégiens qui ont
la chance de partir et et qui vont se
remplit à je l'espère les yeux la tête
et surtout le coeur de belles rencontres
de belles images de l'autre côté de
l'océan indien bénarès les attend sur
les rives du fleuve sacré mais pour
mériter cette cité vieille de 4000 ans
il faudra passer par un voyage de près
de 24 heures au départ de l'aéroport de
gillot
à l'arrivée à bénarès l'atmosphère s'est
réchauffée d'une dizaine de degrés
l'accueil à l'indienne fait vite oublier
la fatigue plus que 45 minutes d'efforts
en russe avant d'atteindre la ville de
temps
comme les engagés indiens voici 150 ans
les collégiens prennent le bateau dès
l'aurore le lendemain matin pour une
heure de navigation seulement comme eux
des milliers de pèlerins indien
rejoignent les rives du gange chaque
jour
les premières négociations en anglais
s'engage avec les vendeurs du fleuve
sur les 84 escaliers appelé gâte de sont
réservés à la crémation l'ultime rituel
dans la vie d'un doute l'espoir de la
réincarnation
la scène qui doit être filmé
discrètement ne laisse pas les
collégiens indifférent le décor
nanterre mais comme ça que
les prêtres brahmine attentes sur la
rive pour les bénédictions
zayed acceptent de se prêter au jeu
aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
indiens pratique l'hindouisme mais
l'inde s'est également la terre qui a vu
naître et rayonner le bouddhisme
plusieurs siècles avant notre ère c'est
un beau de gaia dans l'état du bihar que
le bouddha a connu l'élimination
des vannes à sa porte couleurs des
sponsors et des pêcheurs
comme les prêtres brahmine de bénarès
les moines bouddhistes de bottes gaïa
vivent et étudient grâce aux offrandes
des touristes et de leurs
coreligionnaires même si c'est ici que
l'histoire des enseignements bouddhistes
prend ses racines ces jeunes moines font
partie des minorités religieuses de
l'inde d'aujourd'hui pour les collégiens
se calme sous l'arbre du bouddha c'est
le contexte idéal pour fournir les
carnets de voyage
va pas trop ces temples là et quand je
bosse gaïa n'est pas que le berceau du
bouddhisme c'est également une ville de
l'état le plus pauvre de l'inde le
billard c'est ici que jeanne père et une
enseignante française à la retraite a
décidé de lancer il ya un peu plus de 10
ans une école pour tenter d'offrir un
avenir aux enfants défavorisés hilale
qui a rejoint l'effectif à l'âge de 12
ans aujourd'hui elle enlace aise dans
cette zone rurale où de nombreuses
filles sont encore mariée très jeune
elle peut espérer se tracer un avenir
professionnel a world hors
tabac
il dînait
indignait annonça à omar bin
saud al
aouda yeux
malgré la barrière de la langue le
contact s'établit facilement et souvent
l'apprentissage vient dans l'action
comme lors de massage la grande
spécialité des écoliers
les quelques heures passées avec les
enfants et les choeurs sont déjà gros à
l'idée de repartir les émotions fortes
la chaleur la fatigue et les estomacs de
plus en plus fragilisé donne lieu aux
premiers moments de découragement
lecture qu'est ce qui est dur
m
bonjour
fatigué fait l'arbre car c'est
effectivement un autre voyage dans le
voyage qui attend les élèves le train de
nuit pour rejoindre la capitale une
première pour l'ensemble du groupe
dormir beaucoup oui je pense que
réveil pour le moins difficile pour
certains le lendemain matin même si les
couchettes sont celles d'un wagon de
première classe
et
cette nuit là le groupe a goûté au moyen
de locomotion empruntée chaque jour par
un indien sur 5 sur le deuxième réseau
ferroviaire au monde après les états
unis avec un population plus familiale
des gens qui pensent au
terminus du séjour des lits une
véritable claque urbaine la capitale
indienne est 20 fois plus peuplé que
l'île de la réunion toute entière c'est
d'ici que le groupe décollera dans trois
jours pour rejoindre son île après avoir
parcouru 2800 kilomètres sur les routes
et les chemins de fer du continent dans
cette ville de la démesure le métro est
un moyen de transport indispensable et
une grande découverte pour le groupe de
collégiens
avant que ont pu soit ce pas trop s'y
tient
si les engagés du sucre sont partis du
sud de l'inde pour rejoindre l'île de la
réunion dès le 19ème siècle de nombreux
indiens du nord ont également quitté
leur terre pour les îles de l'océan
indien c'est le cas de la famille de
johnny
et aussi vous amuser
c'est bizarre d'apprendre
ces quinze dernières années la capitale
a hérité des effets de l'ouverture du
pays à l'économie mondiale et avec elle
de la consommation à grande échelle dans
ses centres commerciaux les prix sont
alignés sur les prix européens pas donné
à toutes les bourses indiennes
at-il ensemble
à l'envié des
plus développés ya plus de personnes et
que votre billet ils sont pavées moigne
ans et ça fait bizarre
c'est un gros changement voilà
24 heures après le retour à la réunion
chez fatih atik les petits frères ont
pris possession de leur ensemble
la maman n'a pas encore vidé les valises
et compte bien honorer ses cadeaux dès
la rentrée
lady jamais la maison
ma fille des souvenirs matériel pour les
proches mais surtout des images des
émotions gravé à jamais dans les esprits
des voyages ajouté à 510
jusqu'à 200 après les essences
après on partait après le plus le
comment le vendre est venu à une trousse
pour qu'on revienne pour sopi comprenez
on recense rester trop mal de semaines
qui ont marqué des vies ont fait naître
des leçons des valeurs mais surtout des
promesses
on a dit qu'on voit jamais l'oublier on
sera toujours unis parce qu'on était
toujours à veille on avait le délire on
sent que c'est trop fort